welcome back have you tried dieting this
year you're eating less and moving more
but nothing about your body is changing
our next guest says she is no stranger
to solving these kinds of stubborn
weight problems
i went from a size 14 to a size 6 in 30
days
i no longer suffer from fibromyalgia and
i no longer suffer from depression
today we have dr national on the show
and we're talking about an issue that a
lot of us deal with
we're talking about stubborn fat dr nash
why why can't we lose that stubborn fat
on our belly
and on our thighs yeah right like that's
so
totally annoying so the biggest reason
that we can't seem to lose the stubborn
body fat is because the stubborn body
fat is controlled by something
other than how much we eat and how much
we
move so for more than half the country
if they're dealing with some kind of
underlying problem and in this case it's
usually a hormone problem
then even if i'm eating less and moving
more my body will not respond
in the belly and the butt and the thigh
area it's really frustrating
so what are the top three issues about
weight loss
that your program solves so there's
three
really really big things the first one
is that it gets rid of hunger and
cravings and for most people that is the
number one drawback about why they can't
get to a diet
and stay there the second one is that it
removes
underlying causes that are driving
problems so my program has helped people
reverse their diabetes reverse fatty
liver
reverse high blood pressure and high
cholesterol so we're healing the body as
well as
getting it fitter and then the third one
is that they need
much less exercise to get a much more
accelerated result
so our standard program gets one to two
pounds a week on average
our programs typically get three to
seven pounds a week on average
and you're uh living proof because you
lost 80 pounds we saw the before and
after pictures
i mean so so how how are you able to
keep that weight off you look gorgeous
this is something that i struggled with
since i was eight years old and i kept
doing the traditional approach where i
would eat less and i would move more and
i would see a little bit of results but
not a lot and it was frustrating and i
would just want to dive face deep into a
piece of pie to
solve my woes and and make myself feel
better but it was when i
started looking at these underlying
problems and found out well wait a
minute
there's something else that tells my
body whether or not to burn fat for fuel
and if
those things are shut off i'm not going
to see a change no matter what i do
and it was then that i made the switch i
started
tackling these underlying issues that i
tackle for with my clients
and that's when everything happened i
saw faster weight loss
and the weight stayed off eating normal
levels of calories which is what we all
want
you're enjoying food still this is
unbelievable dr nash what's what's also
unbelievable is every time you come on
here
you bring it special what kind of
special do you have today i absolutely
do
especially in quarantine when my gun we
all know we need a special so
um normally my evaluations are 97 if you
come in my office and talk to me that is
the fee but if you mention that you saw
me on las vegas now with jc
i got 10 evaluations right now sitting
on my website that's
showing somewhere on the screen and it's
less than ten dollars it's only 9.97 to
find out if any of these issues are
going on for you
and to help me get you back to your
normal weight and hold it
living a normal lifestyle